[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen zum Nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem Dienstag die vom Sport hat
Norbert Lehmann einen schönen Montag von
mir und das sind unsere Themen von heute
Debatte um gasumlage die EU-Kommission
bekräftigt die Mehrwertsteuer darauf
muss erhoben werden
erneut Explosionen auf der Krim dort
brennt ein Munitionsdepot die
Sicherheitslage rund um das AKW
saporicia bleibt angespannt
und Gold im kairin Leia Sophie Friedrich
setzt den Siegeszug der deutschen
Sprinterinnen in München fort im
Zehnkampf ist Niklas Kaul immer noch auf
Medaillenkurs
für Gaskunden wird es noch teurer auf
die ab Oktober geplante gasumlage kommt
noch die Mehrwertsteuer stand jetzt
19%, die Bundesregierung hatte sich
vergeblich bei der EU um eine Ausnahme
von der Mehrwertsteuerpflicht bemüht
jetzt will der Bundeskanzler schnell mit
der Kommission verhandeln wie diese
Steuereinnahmen zurück an die Bürger und
Bürgerinnen gehen können Frank Buchwald
hat Details
flüssiges Metall mehr als tausend Grad
heiß oder Gas geht nichts bei dieser
Gießerei in Quedlinburg das Unternehmen
verbraucht so viel Energie wie 500
Einfamilienhäuser die Kosten explodieren
vor allem aber so sagt der Chef braucht
der Planungssicherheit ich gebe ihnen
Beispiel kriegen sie einen Anruf vier
Stunden bevor das Gas weg ist oder vier
Tage oder vier Wochen vorher wie wird
das geregelt und vor allem wann kommt es
wieder eines immerhin ist klar seit
heute Nachmittag auf die geplante
gasumlage kommt zusätzlich nun auch noch
Mehrwertsteuer alles bitten hat nichts
genutzt Brüssel bleibt hart also müssen
nur possibility es gibt keine
Möglichkeit diese Art von Abgabe von der
Steuer zu befreien daher stehen wir in
Kontakt mit der Bundesregierung um
Lösungen zu finden die den
Endverbrauchern nutzen
eine solche Lösung strebt auch der
Kanzler an er werde die Menschen nicht
allein lassen bekräftigt Scholz und
kündigt an diesen Weg werden wir jetzt
ganz schnell mit der Kommission
besprechen dann ist er auch rechtssicher
und kann umgesetzt werden noch bevor die
Umlage erhoben wird
Krisengipfel zum Thema Energie heute
auch in Magdeburg wenig Begeisterung
hier über die Nachricht aus Brüssel
Ministerpräsident hasloff gerade zu
entsetzt
wir haben eine absolute Krisensituation
die uns noch Jahre
hinweggesellschaftlich fordern wird das
kann man in so einer Situation in der
wir jetzt stecken der EU nicht
durchgehen lassen der Oppositionsführer
meldet sich vom Krankenbett und fragt
per Zeitungsinterview gibt es in dieser
Bundesregierung eigentlich
irgendjemanden der angesichts der immer
weiter steigenden Belastungen und der
immer neuen Ankündigungen von
Entlastungen noch den Überblick hat
Berlin in der Zwickmühle diskutiert wird
nur in etwa über eine ermäßigte
Mehrwertsteuer auf Energie 7 statt 19%,
das würde nicht nur die Gießereien
Quedlinburg entlasten und Wirtschaft
ebenso wie Verbrauchern etwas mehr
Planungssicherheit bescheren
das Leben wird immer teurer die
Regierung verspricht weitere
Entlastungen welche Hilfen es bislang
gibt wann Sie ausgezahlt werden und wer
davon profitiert lesen Sie in unserer
ZDF heute App
um die Abhängigkeit von russischen
Lieferungen zu senken soll mehr Erdgas
in flüssiger Form importiert werden vier
deutsche Energieunternehmen vereinbarten
heute mit Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck
die entstehenden Terminals mit maximaler
Menge zur beliefern
LNG also verflüssigtes Erdgas kommt in
Tankern aus Ländern die mit Pipelines
nicht zu erreichen sind der erste
Anleger soll bis Ende des Jahres in
Wilhelmshaven in Betrieb gehen über die
deutschen lngplanungen Christina
iglseder und Oliver deuka
Berlin
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium
Unterschriften die die Sicherheit der
Energieversorgung Deutschlands
garantieren sollen das ist ein wichtiger
Termin in der schritt-reihenfolge die
wir seit Beginn des Jahres gehen und
unabhängig weniger erpressbar zu machen
von Putin von den Gaslieferungen aus
Russland und Deutschland eine
widerstandsfähige gasinfrastruktur zu
geben
willenshafen hier sollen Ende des Jahres
schon Tanker mit verflüssigem Erdgas aus
Übersee anlanden in solchen schwimmenden
Terminals wird es wieder in den
gasförmigen Zustand zurückgewandelt um
es dann ins Leitungsnetz einzuspeisen
der Pipeline baut zum 26 km entfernten
Einspeisepunkt bereits in vollem Gange
muss auch denn die Zeit drängt
irgendwann kriegen wir hier sicherlich
auch November Dezember kriegen wir
vielleicht mal ein bisschen schlechteres
Wetter und schlechtere See auch dann
werden die Arbeiten nicht mehr so
schnell stattfinden können und das sind
die Herausforderungen die wir dann
meistern müssen aber steht LNG auf dem
Weltmarkt dann auch in ausreichender
Menge zur Verfügung und zu welchem Preis
in den hauptlieferländern Australien und
den USA mehren sich bereits die Stimmen
gegen die Ausfuhr immer größerer Mengen
des eigenen Gases und die Lieferverträge
mit dem von Robert Habeck umworbenen
Katar noch immer nicht unter Dach und
Fach mit den Mengen in diesem Winter
wird es wahrscheinlich eher eng
wahrscheinlich im nächsten Winter aber
es ist tatsächlich so dass das am Ende
eine Frage des Preises ist wer zahlt am
meisten für die freien Mengen die auf
dem Weltmarkt zur Verfügung stehen
7,5 Milliarden Kubikmeter Erdgas sollen
in Wilhelmshaven jährlich ankommen das
entspricht etwa einem Fünftel der
fehlenden russischen Erdgaslieferungen
russlands Präsident Putin bleibt sich
treu Schuld am Blutvergießen in der
Ukraine sei der Westen der Grund
liberaler Totalitarismus und
Neokolonialismus schwerer tut sich das
Regime damit eigene Rückschläge zu
erklären etwa neue gewaltige Explosionen
auf der von Russland annektierten Krim
diesmal in einem Munitionslager ein
Sabotageakt so der kremme Pablo silalahi
berichtet
ein riesiger Feuerball über der Krim
wieder brennt eine russische
Militäreinrichtung auf der Halbinsel und
wieder ist unklar wer dafür
verantwortlich ist Russland spricht von
Sabotage doch vieles deutet auf einen
Angriff der Ukraine hin es gab beim
letzten Angriff vor wenigen Tagen kurze
Zeit danach Satellitenbilder auf denen
Einschläge deutlich zu erkennen waren
die russischen Angaben stimmen also
nicht die Ukraine tut allerdings gut
daran nicht genau aufzuklären ob sie
diese Entfernung erreichen kann und mit
welchen Waffensystemen sie arbeitet das
erzeugt Unsicherheit auf der russischen
Seite die Explosionen ereigneten sich im
Norden der Kriminal John Koi erst vor
einer Woche hatte es Explosionen auf dem
Militärflughafen Saki im Südwesten
gegeben Behörden zufolge war auch bei
dieser Detonation ein Munitionslager
betroffen und auch hier ist bis heute
nicht klar wer die Verantwortung trägt
russlands Präsident Putin wirft auf
einer Sicherheitskonferenz bei Moskau
den USA vor die Ukraine als Zitat
Kanonenfutter zu missbrauchen
sie versuchen mit aller Gewalt ihre
Hegemonie und macht aufrecht zu erhalten
die ihnen aus den Händen geglitten ist
sie versuchen Länder und Völker in einer
neokolonialen Ordnung zu halten ihre
Hegemonie bedeutet Stagnation für die
ganze Welt und die ganze Zivilisation
angespannt ist auch die Lage rund um
Europas größtes Atomkraftwerk nahe
saporisha immer wieder gibt es Kämpfe
gestritten wird vor allem um die Frage
wie Inspektoren der internationalen
atomenergieagentur dorthin gelangen
können
zurück nach Deutschland die Hamburger
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft wird nicht
gegen Bundeskanzler Scholz wegen der
cum-ex-affäre rund um die Hamburger
Warburg Bank ermitteln in dessen
Amtszeit als Erster Bürgermeister hatten
die Finanzbehörden darauf verzichtet 47
Millionen Euro aus cum-ex-geschäften von
der Bank zurückzufordern das habe in
deren Ermessen gelegen es gebe keinen
Verdacht auf Beihilfe zur
Steuerhinterziehung erklärte die
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft am Freitag
soll Scholz erneut vor dem Hamburger
Untersuchungsausschuss aussagen
eine Studentin ein Vater und sein Baby
eine Rentnerin und eine Lehrerin alle
fünf stauben im Dezember 2020 in Trier
als ein Mann mit seinem Auto in der
Fußgängerzone auf sie zuraste es gab
etliche verletzte hunderte
traumatisierte Augenzeugen heute kam das
Urteil für den Amokfahrer der 52-Jährige
muss lebenslang in die Psychiatrie an
seinem Stern berichtet
kein Wort hat er gesagt kein Wort zu
seiner Tat zu seinen Opfern Bernd W
schweigt seit einem Jahr auch heute am
Mittag endet der lange Prozess der
Amokfahrer von Trier wird verurteilt
bekommt die Höchststrafe
hier kann die Kammer zu dem Ergebnis
dass eine besondere Schwere der Schuld
aufgrund der Tat Intensität und der
Anzahl der Opfer der schweren Verletzung
anzunehmen ist der 52-Jährige habe waren
Vorstellungen und paranoide
Schizophrenie so ein Gutachten
alleinstehend arbeitslos und frustriert
sei er gewesen sagt der Staatsanwalt bei
seinen Morten habe Bernd Weg gezielt
Jagd gemacht auf Passanten am ersten
Dezember 2020 raste mit seinem Auto
durch die Fußgängerzone in Trier fünf
Menschen sterben hier darunter ein Baby
neun Wochen alt viele werden verletzt
viele traumatisiert
wolfgang hilsemer hat seine Schwester
verloren bei der Amokfahrt war als
Nebenkläger beim Prozess dabei ich bin
erleichtert
hat mich jemand gefragt ob ich zufrieden
wird zufrieden bin ich nicht zufrieden
wäre ich gewesen wenn ich nächste Woche
mit meiner Schwester 75 Jahre geburtstag
gefeiert hätte ist nämlich nächste Woche
ob der Amokfahrer Bernd W mit seinen
Pflicht Verteidigern in Revision geht
ist noch unklar
die Zahl der Diskriminierungen in
Deutschland sei alarmierend hoch sagt
die neue
antidiskriminierungsbeauftragte
förder-attermann sie stellte in Berlin
den Jahresbericht 2021 vor mehr als
5.600 Menschen suchten Rat bei der
antiskriminierungsstelle des Bundes die
meisten 37 Prozent wegen Rassismus 32
Prozent der Fälle betrafen
Benachteiligung wegen Behinderung und
chronischer Krankheit 20 Prozent
Geschlechterdiskriminierung
eine besondere Belastung für die Natur
ist in diesem Jahr nicht nur die Hitze
sondern auch die Trockenheit die Dürre
trifft weite Teile Europas fast die
Hälfte der Fläche 47% ist so trocken
dass die Warnstufe erreicht ist bei 17%
gilt schon die Alarmstufe betroffen sind
auch Flächen in Ostdeutschland über die
Folgen in Thüringen berichtet Florian
koczyk
eine Landschaft die an den Wilden Westen
erinnert doch sie liegt nicht in Texas
oder Colorado sondern im Thüringer
Becken fast nirgendwo in Deutschland hat
es diesen Sommer so wenig geregnet wie
hier mit fatalen Folgen der Mais müsste
zu dieser Jahreszeit eigentlich doppelt
so hoch sein also das Problem ist dass
zum einen das Höhenwachstum fehlt aber
zum anderen sehen wir normalerweise
müssten ein bis zwei Kolben an der
Pflanze dran sein und derzeit befindet
sich eben hier ein sehr sehr
verkümmerter Maiskolben dennoch muss
jetzt geerntet werden sechs Wochen
früher als üblich denn er blüht bereits
und vertrocknet sonst komplett so wie
diese Sonnenblumen abgewandt von der
Sonne lassen sie die Köpfe hängen zu
Hunderttausenden zu extrem waren Hitze
und Trockenheit der letzten Wochen für
die Kulturen die wir in der
Landwirtschaft anbauen ist das eine
Katastrophe gerade bei Sonnenblume
Zuckerrübe oder auch bei Mais den wir
einfach dass das Wasser nicht
ausreichend zur Verfügung steht und wir
deswegen mit mindererträgen bei 60 70 80
Prozent rechnen und auch die Wälder
leiden weil die Wurzeln vieler Laubbäume
kein Wasser mehr Nachrichten sieht es in
der Region um die Wartburg jetzt schon
aus wie im Herbst wir haben ja extrem
Trockenstress bei den Buchen also sie
werfen jetzt das Laub ab verfärben
teilweise schon und manche werfen also
auch als Schutzmechanismus grüne Blätter
ab um also Wasser zu sparen und jetzt
ist halt die große Frage für das
kommende Jahr wie viel Bäume überleben
also in der Regel werden es etwa die
Hälfte nicht schaffen selbst wenn es
jetzt mal regnet hilft das den meta-tief
ausgetrockneten harten Böden nur wenig
und für viele Bäume ist es ohnehin schon
zu spät
jetzt zu seltenen Einblicken aus China
dort steht Präsident hi unter Druck vor
allem in den Großstädten die immer noch
unter extremen corona-auflagen leiden
nun versucht hier die Berichterstattung
auf seine Erfolge zu lenken
internationale Medien bekamen gezeigt
wie sehr sich das Leben auf dem Land
verbessert hat zum Beispiel in der
Region Hunan einer landwirtschaftlich
geprägten Provinz im Süden Chinas unsere
Korrespondentin Miriam Steimer aber bei
der Pressereise dabei
stolz zeigt uns Bauer lieber John das
Gemüsefeld seiner Familie mit
QR-Code
zuerst schaust du dir das Gemüse an und
dann kennst du den Code und kannst
bestellen wie viel du willst
wo er früher von Hand gesät hat gibt es
heute viel Technik riesige Reisfelder
und Rekord ernten das ist ihm besser
geht und wer dafür verantwortlich ist
auch das erzählt uns Bauer Lee
die Beamten arbeiten hart und die
Regierung ist entschlossen die Armut zu
besiegen wir sind den Verantwortlichen
sehr dankbar
es ist eine Art Slogan den er auch sagt
Bauer Lee ist gut vorbereitet auf dieses
Interview nichts passiert hier zufällig
wir sind in Ronan einer
landwirtschaftlichen Provinz im Süden
Chinas auf einer Pressereise organisiert
vom chinesischen Staat und der hat auch
das Thema ausgewählt es geht nicht etwa
um Corona oder Taiwan sondern um
Armutsbekämpfung auf dem Land die
Botschaft die wir transportieren sollen
die Regierung kümmert sich um die
Menschen hier
wir haben die Armut erfolgreich bekämpft
das müssen wir sichern und den
ländlichen Raum im großen Stil
wiederbeleben es ist hießbündnis mit der
Landbevölkerung er hat Milliarden in die
Armutsbekämpfung gesteckt und das Leben
vieler verbessert dafür will er jetzt
ihre Unterstützung wenn er sich im
Herbst eine dritte Amtszeit sichern will
in den Städten wächst der Unmut über
seine corvette-politik die der
Wirtschaft schadet und sein Versprechen
gefährdet das Volk reich zu machen
deshalb ist es für ihn umso wichtiger zu
zeigen wie sehr sich das Leben auf dem
Land verbessert hat zum Beispiel im Dorf
von Bauer Lee
ganz weiter Sprung jetzt nach München zu
den europäischen Championships da gab es
heute wieder Medaillen im Bahnrad für
die Deutschen ja ganz tolle erfolgserie
insgesamt 12 Medaillen davon sieben Mal
Gold Maximilian Dörnbach der holte heute
im Karin Finale Silber und sofort der
zweite Triumph von Lea Sophie Friedrich
in München nach dem Sieg im Teamsprint
gewann sie heute auch den EM-Titel im
karim-wettbewerb
da kommt auch Christina Vogel um zu
gratulieren Lea sowie Friedrich hat nach
der Enttäuschung im Sprint im Keirin
alle hinter sich gelassen ungünstig auf
Platz 5 ausgelost den sie halten muss
bis der Tempomacher vorn endlich Platz
macht sprintet die 22-Jährige schon vor
der Schlussrunde vor auf Platz zwei um
dann auch an der Französin mathild gross
noch vorbei zu fliegen der zweite
EM-Titel von München für die Frau aus
Dassow an der Ostsee
um einen Coach hat mich noch mal so
motiviert und gesagt ey Lea du kannst
das du hast diesen Ehrgeiz und du hast
es drauf deine Beine könnt auf
Startposition drei und vier Maximilian
Dörnbach und Mark jodschick und die
fahren sofort an die Spitze dicht an
dicht müssen auf der letzten Runde aber
den Franzosen wie schee passieren lassen
Maximilian Dörnbach sichert Silber
gestern überraschten uns die
Marathonläufer und Läuferin heute ist es
ein GEA Christopher linke jahrelang
hatte der Potsdamer bei großen
Wettkämpfen eine Medaille verpasst jetzt
der Erfolg bei der em-premiere der 35
Kilometer Distanz
im Silber nach zwei Stunden 29,5 Minuten
trotz Problemen am Schienbein die den
Sportsoldaten auf der Strecke sogar zu
Schmerzmitteln greifen ließen im Ziel
das Happy End für Christopher linke
Zweiter hinter dem Spanier Miguel Lopez
gute Aussichten auf eine Medaille hat
auch Zehnkämpfer Niklas Kaul nach acht
Disziplinen liegt der Weltmeister von
2019 zwar nur auf dem siebten Rang kann
im Speerwerfen und im abschließenden
1500 Meter Lauf am Abend aber seine
Stärken ausspielen und auf Edelmetall
hoffen
auch der frühere WM dritte kai katzmarek
hat als aktuell fünfter noch
Medaillenchancen
und bei der Schwimm-EM in Rom gab es
Bronze für Deutschland Lukas mazarat
wurde über 50 Meter Brust Dritter hinter
den Italienern Nicolo martinegi und
Simone Cerasuolo die zweite Deutsche
sprintmedaille aus Bronze bei dieser EM
ja und schwimmen in Rom und die European
Championships in München die gibt es
morgen bei uns zu sehen um 9:50 Uhr live
im ZDF und wir gehen noch mal nach
München zurück da gab es nämlich heute
eine ganz besonders schöne Szene es
geschah beim Vorlauf über 3000 Meter
Hindernis der bis dahin führende Däne
wann Christensen stürzte mitten im
Getümmel der anderen Läufer Navi
karabene aus Andorra stoppte und half
dem 18-Jährigen Dänen aus der Bahn
weit abgeschlagen musste karabene danach
alleine seine Runden drehen aber das
Publikum war begeistert und belohnte
sein Fairplay mit riesen Applaus
das war es wert hoffe ich statt Sonne
und Hitze gibt es morgen Schauer und
Gewitter wo die Unwettergefahr am
größten ist erfahren sie gleich von
Katja horneffer Bettina Schausten
spricht dem heute journal um viertel vor
zehn mit der neuen
antidiskriminierungsbeauftragten Ataman
wir danken für Ihr Interesse wünschen
Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend und sind
morgen wieder da auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend viele empfanden die Luft
heute als schwül obwohl die Temperaturen
nur bei 26 bis 32 Grad lagen das liegt
daran dass der Wind auf Südwest gedreht
hat und jetzt feuchte Gewitterluft
herankommt denn hier liegt ein
gewittertief über dem Atlantik unter
diesem gewittertief ist es schon
deutlich kühler heute Nacht sinken die
Temperaturen auf Rügen bis auf 19 Grad
am kühlsten wird es in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen oder auch am Alpenrand
mit 11 Grad im Osten ist es meist klar
in der Nacht im Westen gibt es einige
Wolken und zum frühen Morgen kann es im
Westen auch schon die ersten
Regenschauer geben die weiten sich dann
morgen Vormittag über die westlichen
Mittelgebirge aus sonst gibt es noch
sehr viel Sonnenschein zwischen der
Ostseeküste und der Donau am Nachmittag
Quellen die Wolken dann auch hier im
Nordosten aber spannender ist die
Wetterentwicklung hier im denn da gibt
es kräftige Schauer und Gewitter und zum
Abend gibt es genau zwei
gewitterschwerpunkte zum einen hier im
westlichen Niedersachsen und zum anderen
in Baden-Württemberg unter den dichteren
Wolken im Westen liegen morgen die
Temperaturen bei 26 bis 29 Grad sonst
werden 30 bis 34 Grad erreicht und dann
werden die Gewitter richtig
unwetterartig Donnerstag und Freitag mit
hagelplatzregen und Sturmböen guten
Abend